ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty
[Music]
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv all the networks
all the networks person woman
man
[Music]
because i have like a good memory
because i'm
cognitively there
it's a very unpleasant experience
[Music]
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs
oranges oranges she would be a bicycle
god bless the united states thank you
very much
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
which is just
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody a massive
dumps cost of the election
what is going on here what is go
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody
uh massive dumps costing the election
what is going on here
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we have uh
hopefully one
small step in the return
to normalizing relations with our
traditional
uh world allies we are about 20 minutes
away from hearing from
u.s president joe biden and canadian
prime minister justin trudeau
who had a meeting today bilateral talks
and i won't predict what we're going to
hear we will just see what we're going
to hear
in about 20 minutes in the meantime i
have so many things to go over with you
including a david pakman show exclusive
preview
um of something that may never even make
it onto the show it may it may not we
will see
uh i do have a super chat i want to
address it's from avi
avi who says david it's my third time
asking you this
why don't democrats in power pass a
national holiday for election day
or other vote expanding measures well
for other vote expanding measures you'd
have to tell
me what it would be and then it's a
question as to whether it could be
passed and whether it would be worth the
political capital to pass it
in terms of making election day a
national holiday
quite frankly they're not doing it
because it's not it is not an issue on
which there is enough of a clamoring for
as much sense as it would make
uh that it's worth it to them for them
to do it unilaterally
it's uh it's really just that simple
um what else oh this is kind of weird
i don't know if you guys remember from
yesterday if you were here
but by popular demand i got
a gavel it's a cartoonish squeaky gavel
seems to have some kind of mobile
element here some got a button
anyway i got this for when we adjudicate
unban requests on twitch and
yesterday just as a joke i tried it on
my head because it squeaks
as you can hear and i i know that this
sounds crazy
but i'm pretty sure it doing that
broke the clip for my earpiece which
clips to the back of my shirt
i use a very very uh powerful
swiss made vt 600 uh earphone
and it has a little clip see which is
back here
and i think it it broke from
gaveling my own head so i've had to put
in a really strong order for a
replacement clip
from our friends over at bh photo video
who carried just the clip for the vt600
and i am uh it's gonna be in very soon
okay it also i've actually had to
replace the clip before because i've had
this thing for like eight years
so um it might just be that it was time
you know but
that that little squeak it did
seem to maybe do a little bit of damage
it's only a seven dollar clip but the
shipping is a hundred bucks
but it's only a seven dollar clip all
right
okay and speaking of which let's just do
our
soul unban request right now if you've
been banned on twitch and you want to be
unbanned there is a process for
requesting an
unban and we are convening here
as a court of unban requests
a user yesterday said
let's just circle back on any reality we
can't explain
sad and then they were immediately
banned
they appealed by saying i'm not seeing
this as a flagrant error
the circle back comment was about sake's
past explanations
yeah that's that's an unban that's an
absolute unban
and i'm not going to call out the
moderator who did that that's not even
worthy of a temporary timeout ban
so let's let's adjust let's recalibrate
um
and on that one we have decided unban
there it is and the impeachment i'm
sorry not impeachment court the unbanned
court
has been closed but that is certainly
not worthy of an unban
of a ban rather it is worthy of a ban it
was never
worthy of being banned thank you
we are banning bans when unbanned would
be obvious
all right okay a few other super chats
unknown prodigy says i'm hoping to hear
some subtle trump shade from both biden
and trudeau yeah i'm hoping so too
oren says do you think there should be
more of a push to make election day a
national holiday it seems it would
address a lot of voting accessibility
issues
i've seen some uh opinion pieces
which argue that it wouldn't be an
obvious victory
to make election day a national holiday
because there are
other problems that would be caused by
it and
uh let me do a little more research for
me it wasn't that clear the case for it
wasn't that obvious that that was the
solution
i think a longer period for voting which
will sort of encompass
all sorts of different schedules and
types of employment might be a better
way to go
and there it is users on twitch very
quickly saying extending early voting
makes more sense i agree
nicolas says your big brain broke the
gavel of the battleground of ideas right
jay harmon says does anyone realize ted
cruz looks like a real-life simpsons
character
oh this is actually interesting uh
cancun cruise today
check this out they were there were
hearings today about the insurrection
from january 6th
let me get this properly set up and ted
cruz was caught on camera
he's on his phone just scrolling and it
actually looks like he's quickly tapping
i'm almost wondering if he's playing
like a candy crush type game here take a
look at this
based on the intelligence that we
received we plan for an increased level
of violence at the capitol
and that some participants may be armed
but there it is
the intelligence we received predicted
what actually occurred
for some reason i imagine that he's
playing snood or something like that
extensive look at him tapping away on
that thing may be armed
but none of the intelligence we received
predicted so he's really very much keyed
in as you can see on the proceedings and
the proceedings were completely nuts
here's senator ron johnson casually
mentioning there might have been no
bona fide trump supporters at the
insurrection it was all
fake trump protesters listen to this
insanity
thousands of people i passed for who
passed me along constitution avenue some
were indignant
and contemptuous of congress but not one
appeared angry or incited to riot
many of the marchers were families with
small children many were elderly
overweight or just plain tired or frail
trace not typically attributed to the
riot prone many wore pro-police shirts
or carried pro-police black and blue
flags
although the crowd represented a broad
cross-section of americans mostly
working class by their appearance and
manner of speech
some people stood out a very few didn't
share the jovial friendly earnest
demeanor of the great majority
some obviously didn't fit in and he
describes
four different types of people
plainclothes militants
right agents provocateurs fake trump
protesters and then disciplined uniform
column of attackers i think these are
the people that
probably plan this he goes on the d.c
metropolitan police were their usual
professionally detached cells
standing on curbs are at street
crossings and exchanging an occasional
greeting for marchers
when we crossed first street northwest
to enter the capital grounds where the
capitol police had jurisdiction
i noticed no police at all several
marchers expressed surprise
they opened to seem like a courtesy
gesture from congress which controls
security
okay so anyway needless to say it was
everybody other than actual trump
supporters
complete and total clown that is that is
ron johnson all right so there it is
uh i'll have full coverage of those
hearings tomorrow
um kyle wants to know what's my opinion
on term limits for senators and maybe an
age limit at least wondering your
thoughts and known paths and any known
paths to this becoming a law
it's not on route to becoming a law
anytime soon i am in favor of term
limits for senators
absolutely and you can find uh clips
i've done on that uh
on my youtube channel have discussed it
quite a bit and i encourage you to check
it out a big big thank you
to jay harmon for gifting a sub on
twitch as well as big lanky for
subscribing as well as
actual one uh three people three perfect
sign ups on twitch so far putting us
at three for the day and i do wanna let
you know we have
fixed the coupon code okay the coupon
code better21 on my website
joinpakman.com
it has been fixed it is working
and i encourage you to grab such a we
finally fixed the coupon code i know it
hasn't been working for years
uh it now works and you can take you can
avail yourself of that
and i will i will give a shout out to
everybody who signs up
while the gop is too far gone i do feel
our democracy requires
sensible loyal opposition i don't
disagree billy
and billy goes on to say ideally we'd
have a variant of the democratic party
that's more centrist in some areas and
more progressive than others well
the democratic party is centrist what we
need is something to the left of the
democratic party
and certainly if the republican party
also came to the left then we would just
be better off in general
pedro says feeling conflicted with
manchin's opposition to tanden's
nomination
versus helens the former feels justified
the latter just petty i
agree but also i mean listen i don't
like nera tandon as a nominee and i when
joe biden released his nominees
when he dumped the names i said i'm
against nira tandon
she's the worst of the establishment
democratic party center for american
progress
bad bad bad bad like weaponized bad the
reason mansion gives
for opposition is ridiculous because he
voted for kavanaugh
i mean give me a break it's completely
pathetic
nick says from london ontario i'd like
to say welcome back united states thank
you
midge says i never understood term
limits term limits don't get rid of
lobbyists logically there would still be
corruption but they're not yeah term
limits only addresses
one element of the problem
scott says tried the coupon code doesn't
work
pacman it's weird because people are
using it
let's do a test let's test the coupon
code
okay let me see here i like yearly
because yearly is a bigger discount i
hit sign
up okay coupon code field
better 21.
oh no it actually isn't working today oh
my god it's hanging
can you imagine it actually seems not to
be working
for the first time ever oh and there it
worked oh that was a weird glitch
maybe there were just a bunch of people
using it at once that's weird no now it
is working
now it is working that was weird i
almost had to adjudicate it
not working but it is working perfectly
okay good
all right so we've gotten that out of
the way very much appreciate that
um okay now that you have the gavel you
have no excuse not to defend
debate kent hovind i don't know who that
is
have you ever considered if maybe to
split california into three states to
get legitimate representation of six
senators
yes i have covered that i have covered
that on the show and it is very
very interesting as an idea
okay let's do something very very
special here
alright as many this is an exclusive i
don't even know if this will make it
onto the david pakman show podcast
tv show radio show all that stuff as
many of you
may know we get about 6 000
different messages every day if you
include
youtube comments facebook messages
instagram messages website emails tweets
to the show account and on
and on and on and on about six thousand
a day
so on our website it says very clearly
if you go to contact us
i i don't read every email and i
certainly can't respond i can't engage
in political discussions via email
some people get really mad about that
okay i mean
i don't my job is my job is to do the
show it's not to answer
emails but today
an email was brought to my attention
from a really
kooky cuckoo for coco puffs or kooky use
whatever term you want
anti-vaxxer and i actually decided
for the good of the show for content
for the lulz whatever phraseology you
want to apply to it
i decided to actually respond
and see if we can learn something about
anti-vaxxerism okay
i'm gonna give you guys the conversation
so far
and you are going to be stunned by this
okay i got an email this morning from
a concerned viewer named amy
and amy said just curious how could you
deceive
others when it comes to the covid
and the vaccines i'm well aware that you
know
you being me that it's all a scam and
the so-called vaccines are causing
deaths is money
that important to you that you have to
go along with this like who would pay me
to say
i'm i got my vaccine and we should get
vaccines like who
why would anyone pay me to say that
that's crazy people are starting to
despise you
and you they've despised me for a long
time has nothing to do with vaccines
and you don't have to believe me but all
traders involved in this scam
will see a prison cell it's
already mentioned in a couple lawsuits i
know of so keep on with your nonsense
and you will see
now again we get 6 000 messages a day
about 10 or this bonkers but this
actually seemed like maybe someone where
we could learn
something okay so
i responded and i said no one has died
from the vaccine
we will not spread dangerous propaganda
on
our show and amy was
wired up from this and responded to me
two times this gets really good guys i i
settle in get the popcorn okay amy says
i have proof i also have proof from cdc
documents we are being played
the fact that you don't even ask about
the proof i have proves you are involved
in this scam
so now i'm interested okay she says
that um the vaccines are causing deaths
okay send me the send me the documents
um where was the other part it's
mentioned in a couple of lawsuits
send me the documents okay i have proof
from cdc documents that we are being
played
so i write back and i say oh this is
this is the same one
uh oh before i even i get her she's so
wound up she sends me another email i've
not even responded yet
where she says just curious
how you could deceive others when it
comes to the covet and the wait no hold
on this is the original one what am i
looking at
oh no it's almo this is the same one
sorry okay i don't know why this one is
back in here
let's skip that okay so i write back
okay send it
she says i have proof i also have proof
from cdc documents
she's shocked and appalled i haven't
asked for the proof so i say
send it send me the proof
all right everybody with me so far i
know i just got it got a little
confusing there
okay everybody's with me very good the
response is
no documents you know exactly what's up
there are cdc documents admitting were
being played
lawsuits filed saying we are being
played mike pompeo was asked
one time if kovid was a hoax he wouldn't
answer that's for political reasons
it's not for science reasons as for the
fake vacs
why would fouchy get caught fake getting
it i have that proof
too there's all kinds of death reports
and the list of proof goes on and on you
do know all this
so think about everything we have now
that she's offered right
um the vaccines are causing deaths
a couple lawsuits
cdc documents okay
i say send them she now brings up
lawsuits filed pompeo
fake vacs fauci faked it has proof of
that does death reports all this
different stuff
i'm just waiting for the docs okay
so then i say please send me the
document so i can review them lawsuits
and documents
i i'm i want the docs okay send me the
documents
amy writes i'll get the info together
now
however so now it starts to step back
however i feel like this is a trick
because i know how you people work
you all want to know what info we have
so you can scrub it from the internet
what i'm not stupid and i don't trust
anyone
there's no way you don't know this
especially doing what you do so first
she's mad i didn't ask for the documents
now she's suspicious that i did okay
this is how conspiratorial thinking
works let's continue
while i'm getting the info here is the
name of one attorney dealing with a
lawsuit
reiner romick hold on a second
wait a second that name actually let me
let me search something
rule mc okay no okay that's nothing fine
very let's continue and a question still
is why wouldn't mike pompeo answer when
asked if coveted was a hoax
he didn't answer because it was a
political thing that was
the trump administration was wrapped up
in that's not proof of anything
why would dr fauci fake getting the
so-called vaccine okay
so now she's worried if she sends the
documents is going to be a trick
right so now let's continue she says
i'm getting the info together and like i
said reiner romick is one of the
attorneys and he admits it's fraud and i
made it clear it's no trick
i want to see the info i'm just waiting
waiting for the info from amy so then
she says she found that she found
everything remember all the things she's
promised
documents proof of this proof of that
people died all this different stuff
now amy says i just ran across this
about the inventor of the tests they're
using for kovid
he tells you it can't detect if you're
sick notice how they remove the video
because it's truth
like i said earlier you all want to know
what we have so it can be scrubbed
anyway here's some extra proof
now this article is nothing you look at
this article
pcr inventor it doesn't tell you that
you are sick right
pcr tests are measuring for indicators
of whatever it is you are testing for
you might have that in your system and
not be sick
that's not new that's not unique to
covid tests
it has nothing to do with what we're
talking about but remember
she promised me oh hold on wait a second
there it is she promised me cdc
documents
lawsuits proof that the vaccines are
killing people
and now all she finds is an article that
says pcr tests don't necessarily tell
you
if you're sick so i wrote back and i
said
you said amy you had proof the vaccine
is killing people
this is an article about testing can you
send the articles you mentioned about
vaccines as well as the lawsuits
that was seven hours ago and i've not
heard back from her
okay so the le what is the lesson here i
don't really know what the lesson is but
i guess the lesson is when you see
someone this certain about things that
they are saying it starts with this
it ends up with nothing it ends up with
nothing at all she is able to present me
nothing whatsoever so i hope that that's
uh
sort of informative to people that's one
trip down the rabbit hole i guess i was
red pilled by her
or something i don't even understand but
it's crazy
that's uh we'll see if i hear back
otherwise i don't know if that's worthy
of a segment on the podcast
thanks to the freak for 12 months
subscribed to twitch prime
as well as red team go 88
then mailman and a bunch of other great
people
have signed up via twitch in fact four
people putting us at seven
a whole bunch of people have also
uh signed up on my website and i wanna
thank
every single one of you
first thanks to chance baker for signing
up on my website
thanks to leah sutton thank you leah
very much appreciate andrew anderson
signing up at joinpackman.com
shayna baswick is a new member at
joinedpakman.com
david williamson has signed up lucky
andrade
has signed up one two three four five
six okay i'm counting
six and also a big thank you to bree
schmidt
thanks bri new member number seven
putting us at a total of 14 for the day
i very much appreciate that yeah one of
the things that that some people are
pointing out is
with a conspiracy theorist anything
becomes part of the conspiracy
first the fact that i didn't ask for the
documents was part of the problem
then it was suspicious that i asked for
the documents
she also believes that i have the power
to scrub
documents from the internet my guess is
if i hear back from her
she'll say now she can't find the
documents
because they've been scrubbed and that's
part of the conspiracy
this we did a very interesting interview
a few months ago
about how conspiratorial thinking works
these are all elements of it
these are all elements of it and i think
it's important that we call it out
all right other super chats here
try uh oh uh oh evan says tried to use
the better 21 coupon code but i got
detained
by the fbi interrogated for hours they
said something about
criminally low prices that is a risk
anytime you try to sign up on my website
ms smith says hi from the uk do you feel
the supreme court ruling against trump
will really get him in a courtroom
so the supreme court ruling against
trump has nothing to do with getting him
in a courtroom the supreme court ruling
if you're referring to yesterday's on
taxes
is merely that he has to turn over his
tax returns
to the manhattan district attorney
that's all it is unless i'm
i'm missing uh something else
finn says boris johnson's hair can you
imagine i know
i know ali reza says you had a clip
about dc becomes the 51st state
how about combining the dakotas should
some california electoral points be
given to texas due to population moving
there
that all gets handled uh with the census
so all of those questions are going to
be answered my friend
no need to worry kyle says terms slash
age limits for senators
plus eliminating lobbyist corporate
donors is legitimate government let's
make it happen yeah you've got to deal
with lobbying as well of course
okay got to deal with both
thanks to geek greg for gifting five
subs on twitch appreciate that
elias would love to see a show with bo
of the fifth column i'd be up for that
light of the twin lamps says oh glorious
pacman please have mercy in your heart
and ask your discord mods to unban
hector 8474 i don't know anything about
it
you'd have to talk to them uh
kyle comes in out of nowhere and says
this woman sounds like the amy from
gordon ramsay's kitchen nightmares she
only trusts
cats she needs answers right meow
i am not familiar with ken hovid
is dr dyno the creationist nut job who
debates atheists and scientists
sk destiny oh stephen kenneth destiny
benell iii
argued brilliantly against hovind before
okay fair
do you think trudeau will be visibly
relieved to work with an adult as
president i believe so yeah
certainly i love watching u.s politics
to imagine what the 1960s
european-australian new
era policy conversations were like but
in hd
the talk of communism is also great yeah
it's a wild time
and na ba says if we hear nothing else
about these emails
i guess that amy's referencing it proves
pacman is deep state
right right
all right so we're all caught up as far
as that goes also i
am aware of the tiger woods news and
tiger woods was in a very serious car
accident there is a
a sheriff's press conference scheduled
for the top of the hour
it's not the type of thing i would
normally look to stream
but if the timing works out with this
biden trudeau event
we will go over to it all right so we
will uh we will stand by
big thank you also to ky dizzle b
for gifting seven subscriptions
we still have um hold on who
are our top donors ever
of subs i had that information oh i
think because there's a hype train going
on i can't access it that's too bad
inconsolable is still the top gifter
with over 500 gifted subs on the channel
i don't remember who david chadman i
think is number two
and yeah i believe that that is it
uh moderator yeah let me see if i can
pull that up more than 500 yeah it's an
absolutely brutal brutal number
um
oh i do have one other band to
adjudicate
let's a call to order the twitch
unban request court there it is
okay this is a user called no culture
whose
participation in the channel was as
follows
twitch court is now in session joe biden
is a pedophile
joe biden lied about the 2k white lives
matter
white lives matter they were then banned
and their unbanned request was white
lives
matter with absolutely no hesitation or
uncertainty whatsoever
this court takes no pleasure in making
this decision but it is the decision
that must be done
this will be a denied unban
request that is going permaban
and this concludes uh this
unbanned request court that is
permanently a ban
and i think everybody in the chat knows
that
yeah that's it's over it is over
okay kyle says can't say i'm too hopeful
about the future prospect of the country
we have been flipping democrat
republican for god knows how long
abolish the electoral college well said
my friend
light of the twin lamp says if the u.s
collapsed overnight what country would
you flee to
listen if the question is just if i had
my choice of places
i would probably be looking at either
switzerland or some of my other favorite
northern european social democracies
uh denmark is absolutely fantastic
you know the places i've talked about
that are really great places
um maybe just for convenience canada
montreal one of my favorite places
if it's places where i could legally go
i think i'm down to argentina or israel
and um it's chaos in argentina right now
uh cronyism with the sputnik vaccine i
guess i wouldn't have to worry about the
vaccine since i
i i got the modern a first dose and i'm
about to get the second one
but i mean i think my choices would be
israel and argentina right now i think i
think it would have to be israel
um from my my legitimate choices
let's see what else we've got alvaro
says have you followed the individuals
arrested due to the capital riots yes to
some degree
i would suggest sedition hunters on
twitter
to get you to your viewers to help catch
them
all right i will check that out
covering this event is an honest day's
work
making true dough nicely done
you must be a father daniel grant says
has david heard of the great
reset conspiracies yes i have
timothy says i think you missed my
earlier chat and i feel my human rights
have been violated alerting the u.n
let's see timothy what do i think of
murray bookchin i actually don't know
who that is
let's see murray bookchin
murray bookchin was an american
anarchist political philosopher
trade union organizer and educator a
pioneer in the environmental movement
sounds very interesting oh develop the
theory of social ecology and urban
planning very interesting i
that sounds fascinating um
my guess is from his name that he is
uh from from the old country as we might
say
yeah russian jewish immigrants yep seems
like an interesting guy
i will i will research further taylor
says i would much prefer a rubber
chicken sound effect for the unbanned
denial ruling he's
here's five bucks towards purchasing a
chicken
that i don't know uh i i think if i were
to do that i would have to do some kind
of sound
board there actually are sound boards we
could use
i just don't know if they would be
particularly useful
um let me see like for example
let's see uh i thought it was terrific
um
it was clean it was nice
and the bed was good that's like a for a
clean unban
and if we have to maintain a ban then
maybe it would be like
uh let me see what would it be maybe
like this
[ __ ] or i don't care
i don't know barack obama bernie sanders
donald trump yeah i don't know i think
i'm gonna stick with the uh with the
gavel for now
i think the gavel's working pretty well
for us
um okay
oh i missed a few here oh have i heard
you liked visiting montreal
did you know kamala harris lived here
during her teenage years and she
attended the same school as
leonard cohen i did not know that you
know we have a friend
in the um this is so funny we have a
friend
in canadian parliament it is a guy with
one of the coolest names i've ever heard
he follows me on twitter anthony house
father
anson anthony house father mp is a
canadian member of parliament
representing the riding of mount royal
on the island of montreal
um this is one of our this is one of our
friends
i don't know if anybody is represented
by this guy but that is a fantastic
last name one of the best last names
arguably i've ever heard anthony house
father
and uh if i ever get back up to montreal
i hope to
get together with him let's see what
else we've got have i ever thought of
going to mexico i've been to mexico many
times
and i am planning to google uh search uh
flights to cancun
once this press briefing starts actually
excuse me will we be getting a season
two of david's garden this year yes in
fact i have exciting news about that
uh we have a very interesting crossover
one of my favorite youtube channels is
kevin espiritu's epic gardening
okay right now go to his instagram go to
his youtube channel and tell him david
pakman sent you with peace and love
uh my plan is to send a picture of my
setup to kevin very soon
and then have him advise me on
what upgrades i can get to my planter
beds because we need bigger
cukes we need bigger zooks this season
i don't think he's on twitch but he did
ask me about
maybe doing some uh live streaming at
some point okay so that's that
oh by the way there's another youtube
channel i wanted to recommend let me see
if i can find this
um oh how am i gonna find this
oh maybe i can't there's a guy i know
who started a cooking youtube channel
he only has like a thousand followers
thai cooking
it's fantastic let me see
if i can find it uh
no it's gonna be it's good i'll have to
have it ready for the next um
this this is someone who their channel
is so small right now
that they would be shocked if we sent
them a massive dump of subscriptions
no i'm not able to find it i just wasn't
prepared i apologize
yeah it'll be for next time it'll be for
next time like completely authentic from
scratch thai food
all right let's move on uh oh i'm sorry
i i
there's so many people i'm supposed to
be thanking
um asf clops has subbed with prime and
says absolutely loving the twitch unban
unban request trails keep up the great
work david
billy quizboy subscribed for three
months
and pilot dog for six months in total
um 24 wow
24 people just subscribed via twitch
putting us at 38. i also want to say
thank you to kathy
lenahan for signing up at joinpacman.com
travis stop fourth who just signed up on
my website
janet chandler as well as christopher
adcock that's
four christy hartwine
has signed up on my website forrest
nelson is new member number six
and asim amin also signed up that's
seven
at joinpackman.com putting us at 45.
very much appreciate that guys really do
very very much appreciate it okay so
that was
a tangent based on the gardening
question in two sentences why do you
think israel has had a successful
vaccination campaign
oh did you guys hear that
is one of these live no none of them is
live israel has had a successful
successful
vaccination campaign because they made
an early deal with pfizer in exchange
for full
strong data and there's not that many
people in the country
those are the reasons
uh moderators on twitch and youtube
stand back and stand by for
anti-semitism okay
anti-semitism is insta-ban moderators on
twitch and youtube i should have known i
was stepping into a minefield with that
uh get ready for the ban hammers okay
please have them at the ready because i
can already see the direction it's going
thank you
who do you think will win the arm
wrestling match when they shake hands
yeah i don't expect um i don't expect
that to go down
but let's look at remember trump trump's
handshake
games those were so funny
let's see if we can find one here
what was this one i don't even think
i've seen this one
trump going in for the handshake
then settled for a backslap senator
that's weird
i like the uh oh this trump's handshake
troubles are significant
i like that one the walk by
um there's one with macron that's really
good
where is the macron one
trump handshake macron that may be the
one of my favorites this one right here
where it just like goes on
and then you've got the pat and then the
shake and that pulls him in and he's
still going
and then now they're in kind of like a
something else i don't even know
what's this one called
i don't even remember what that one's
called so there was that one
what was the other handshake one was
that the one with shinzo
yeah i think this is it
oh god hold on i missed it let me go
back
[Music]
[Music]
now it's getting weird
this is my favorite moment right here
this is the moment
arguably the best moment of any uh if
you look at us
japanese relations for the trump era the
two best moments were
this and when shinzo abe's wife
pretended not to speak english to not
have to speak to melania that and that's
a true story
that's been widely widely reported
uh okay oh i've got a lot of stuff to
close out here
okay very good so we are caught up
there we're standing by for joe biden
and justin trudeau
we also just by chance are kind of
standing by for this
tiger woods press conference tiger woods
in a very serious car accident
not really the type of thing we would
normally cover but if we happen to catch
it
we will look at it let's see what's
going on here
this person doesn't seem to know she's
on camera investigation of this there
was another traffic collision that
happened with
people being looking loose and but that
thankfully there was no injuries
associated with that the vehicle
traveled several hundred feet from the
center
uh center divider at the intersection
and rested on the
on the west side of the road in the
brush sustained major damage the vehicle
you've seen all the images of that
and uh with that our lamina sheriff
station will be conducting the traffic
investigation
and they'll take them from days to
several weeks to get the whole thing
together
once the in the investigation is
completed we will provide a detailed uh
report it'll be available you know based
on public record act request
and we will not discuss it any further
after that point
but this point i want to introduce chief
daryl osby l.a county fire department
hey by the way this is just a curiosity
because some people have been mentioning
it as soon as the biden trudeau event
starts we're going to go right over to
it
good afternoon i'm fire chief daryl osby
of the los angeles county fire
department at approximately 7
22 this morning resources from los
angeles county
fire station 106 received a report of a
solo vehicle accident at the
intersection of hawthorne boulevard
and polish verdi's drive north in
rolling hills estates
upon arrival at the scene of the
incident of sheriff's on scene
resources and personnel from the los
angeles county fire department
observed a single rollover vehicle
incident with one person
trapped the person trapped
was extricated by the los angeles county
fire department personnel
earlier it was stated that the jaws of
life was utilized
to extricate the person trapped
it was later determined by our personnel
that a halogen tube
which is used for prime and the x was
also
used to pry the person free from the
vehicle
all right so we're going to get away
from this they clearly aren't going to
be able to nor
nor would we expect them to comment on
tiger woods
medical condition which seems to be what
people are wondering about and
i think it's not really on brand with
this live stream
to air that necessarily i don't know it
just it seems like it's not
really for us so we're gonna stand by
here for the joe biden event
uh with justin trudeau which is going to
be starting
um very very soon scheduled for 15
minutes ago
and it should be starting shortly
uh okay other super chats jacob says
hold on a second where did that go where
did jacob go
now that the usmca is signed in asia is
less stable do you think it would be
wise to revisit the trans-pacific
partnership
not for any not not because of the usmca
no i wouldn't say that sitcom court is
in session how do you respond to charges
of
fraudulently claiming seinfeld is better
than fraser
it's not even close
let's even do a straw poll among our
audience
just to see i i think that we have a
seinfeld audience but let's see
which is better whoops
seinfeld frasier we want
spam prevention all right let's just see
what our audience thinks i would be
shocked
if our audience is a frasier audience
i'm pasting the straw poll link
in twitch and youtube chat i'll vote
seinfeld
people know my vote so i don't think
that's a surprise let's see
i i think that we have a seinfeld
audience
let's take a look at the results voting
is on now
uh takes a moment i guess for the first
votes to be tallied do we know why it's
still at zero let's refresh here
this is weird how are we not having any
votes
i just pasted the link in twitch chat a
second time
and in youtube as well
huh it might be broken that's weird
it's letting me vote again that's
strange let's just go straight to
results
oh oh oh hold on a second i pasted the
results
link i think hold on
all right i'm pasting it again
i don't know what the hell is going on
now
all right well it failed no problem
uh i'm gonna i am sure
i'm making an executive decision i'm
sure that seinfeld is more popular with
my audience than uh
than than fraser let's continue david
have you read austerlitz by w.g
seybald i have not i have not
uh colton wants to know if i can wish uh
colton's cousin annie a happy birthday
yes
annie happy birthday i hope that it's
absolutely fantastic
and uh thanks colton for being here
today shamika says david just wondering
when are you going to address the andrew
cuomo nursing home disaster in new york
we've been addressing it uh for since
last week on the bonus show
uh we we have been talking about it and
we will we will continue to talk about
it
emmanuel julia says anthony house father
is my mp cheers from montreal beautiful
who's your favorite founding father and
why yeah that's like saying who's my
favorite president i i just
i don't know i have i i'm terrible at
answering those things
doug says third time to super chat no
shouts
getting vaccine tuesday alabama
beautiful doug
good luck with that looking forward to
you being vaccinated
and anna says thoughts on cuomo's
nursing home scandal yeah we've been
talking about that on the bonus show
so i try not to like redo content
but we have been discussing that all the
frasier votes broke the straw poll says
bronx bjorn i highly doubt that
i am sure that that is not the case big
thank you to justin thompson thanks
justin for signing up on my website
justin is new member number 46 today we
also
just had an additional three
twitch subscribers come in thanks to
evan lutt's music
who has subscribed for nine months
alexander the grape
who has been subscribed for eight months
and aj4au
who has been subscribed for six months
appreciate that uh okay here's an
interesting question david who's your
favorite backstreet boy
or spice girl my favorite backstreet boy
is justin timberlake and my favorite
spice girl is the british one
all right never ask me that again thank
you
david what's keeping you from moving to
a country that's more in line with your
political views
that's a no comment and as many of you
know i am all over the place
and i may already be in such a country
may already be in such a country yani
nicole says david both sitcoms can
co-exist they were both excellent in
their time we don't need to choose of
course we don't yeah i've
i'm fine with people watching frasier it
was just never my show
you know that's it that is it
uh but i have no problem i mean listen
the truth is
curb's the better show better than all
of them
oh some people are demanding i go back
to the tiger woods thing all right let's
see
let's see what they're saying
no no skid marks no braking so
apparently the first contact was with
the center median
and from there then crossed into the
opposing lane of traffic
hit the curb hit a tree and there was
several
uh rollovers during that process
in excess of 45 50 55 miles an hour
that they're gonna have to figure that
one out that's why the traffic investors
would make the the big bucks that they
make
sheriff what can you tell us about this
condition now are you still in touch
with mr wood's team
uh we've reached out we've been in touch
with it with his manager
and they didn't want to release anything
on his condition we heard that he's out
of surgery
and perhaps been moved to his own
sheriff all we know that a serious
condition as a result of the accident
and that's about all they want to say
in this accident weather is not a factor
sure
well we arrived on scene at 7 18 they
were notified within four minutes
and um
we got the call from the sheriff's
department at approximately
7 22 this morning our resources arrived
unseen
at approximately 7 28. i don't have the
information right now in relation to how
long
it took to extricate him from the
vehicle do you have any indication if
there are drugs or medications involved
and why
he was heading that way no who called it
in did someone call 9-1-1 a bystander
and is there any indication he fell
asleep with the wheel
we had a neighbor call the call 9-1-1
that's how the call was received at the
station
is it possible he fell asleep at the
wheel no evidence of impairment this
time they'll be
subject to the investigation what
exactly
what impairments are you looking for
well we're looking at signs of uh inflow
under the influence
of either narcotics medication alcohol
odor of alcohol all these different
things that would give you
an idea in their behavior but there was
not an unpresent
here he could have fallen asleep had a
heart attack now we're going beyond what
we have at the time so that'll take the
investigators will have to figure that
one out
vehicles now have essentially a black
box that reports certain information
about how fast the car is going did
airbags deploy telemetry that sort of
thing did this vehicle have that well
and will you get information from that
of the investigation the investigators
will be able to
if they have it they'll be able to have
that and download it and that will give
us a good idea
[Music]
uh following the vehicle
now that we're aware of sheriff you said
that he was
uh conscious i believe was he able to
communicate how much pain he was in
whether or not it was able to
communicate at all he was able to
communicate he was conscious i'll leave
it at that
we don't know what the speed was but it
was considerable based on the departure
point from the
there's
[Music]
well we got the call at 7 12 and that
came from the neighbors so we have to
assume that
they made that call almost immediately
as soon as it happened because
the neighbors are sitting right within
50 feet
of the location so so they saw the crash
happen
all right so there's that next we will
go to the daft punk
breakup press conference by popular
demand
um if indeed it coincides with uh
the other things that we are doing here
okay a few other super chats are coming
in
um nicholas says people are saying mike
pillow is going to release the evidence
of the fraud in the poll very soon
yeah any day now we're going to get all
that evidence from mike pillow
brian asks david do you feel as if your
rights are being violated by being kept
from becoming president due to your
immigration background yeah
i believe my civil rights have been
violated because i wasn't born in the
united states
and they're not letting me be president
it is what it is as they say
joe rader says tigers should have bought
a tesla
eugene says whose duty is it to take up
the task of deprogramming is it
localized talking to one loved one by
loved one or is there a governmental
role
well this is what we this is the retail
versus the wholesale strategy
the the retail strategy of trying to
deprogram individual
individual people in your life that's
one thing
at a wholesale strategy we have to start
with education
and go to media and so many other things
these are
two aspects of the programming that can
happen
at the same time and and really have to
happen at the same time
check out my five or six clips over the
last months about deprogramming
trumpists
chakaseki says what did you think of
senator john kennedy's incoherent
rambling and flaccid questioning of
merrick garland
about kennedy possibly being racist
uh i didn't see that let's take a look
at that
so this is kennedy garland
racist let's see if we can find it about
this concept of implicit bias
yeah does that mean i'm a racist
no matter what i do or what i think
i'm a racist but i don't know i'm a
racist that's right
okay the label racist is not one that i
would apply
uh like that implicit bias just means
that every human being
has biases that's part of what it means
to be a human being
garland is like whatever you think about
merrick garland he actually is a
brilliant guy
and it was made so evident yesterday
like you could be like oh he's not
progressive enough for me okay fair
um it did it was actually very
interesting i didn't see this clip
and the point of examining our implicit
biases
is to bring our conscious mind up to our
unconscious mind
okay and then i guess there's another
one about this concept of implicit bias
yeah okay so let's skip ahead racist but
i don't know i'm a racist
okay the the label racist is not one
that i would apply
uh like that implicit bias just means
that every human being
has biases that's part of what it means
to be a human being
and the point of examining our implicit
biases
is to bring our conscious mind up to our
unconscious mind
and to to to to know when we're behaving
in a stereotyped way
everybody has stereotypes it's it's not
possible to go through life without
working through stereotypes and implicit
biases
are the ones that we don't recognize our
behavior that doesn't make you racist no
who judges that
doesn't the person judging me have his
own
implicit bias how do i know his implicit
bias isn't worse than mine plus advice
i i agree but i'm not judging you
senator and i don't know i'm not asking
you who would be judging but somebody if
you say you have implicit bias that's a
pejorative statement
it's funny implicit bias isn't really
pejorative any more than it's pejorative
to say
uh people have an availability bias
where when you think about
um you know what color cars are there
you're more likely to list colors that
are that are
predominant you're unlikely to say oh
well
indigo is a really common car color no
you're going to go to the colors that
are that are around you that's it's not
pejorative to recognize
a bias i'm not saying you're being mean
you're not a mean guy that's obvious
you're a nice guy
if you say somebody has implicit bias
somebody's got to make that subjective
judgment and the person making that
subjective
judgment has implicit bias this guy's
really dumb
like really this is this is weaponized
ignorance being a human
then how do you know who wins fair
enough but if we say that all people
have implicit bias it's not uh you
shouldn't take it as pejorative
exactly okay so i'm glad that garland
got to it's not pejorative
this is just an element of the human
condition
wow that's one of those examples where
the level at which merrick garland's
thinking on these issues exists
it's not even in the sa it shouldn't
even be in the same legislative chamber
as
senator kennedy it's it's really
stunning to see
uh it's like a grand canyon between the
two on their ability to
get given the lack of knowledge that
kennedy has i think garland did a good
job but it's
wow wow how is it that kennedy gets to
decide if garland is attorney general
that's
my takeaway from that how on earth do we
let kennedy have a vote
bonkers okay other super chats coming in
oh sorry thanks to miles joseph for
subscribing with twitch prime also
thanks to inconsolable for gifting a
subscription
to a user who goes by the name
aerodynamic fetus
very much appreciate that that is two
additional twitch subscribers
putting us at 51.
also want to say thank you to nick
zlever
or zlavor nick zlavor for signing up at
joinpackman.com using that perfect
coupon code better21
appreciate that as well other super
chats coming in
do you think joe biden's age precludes
an incumbent run in 2024 and if so
who would you like to see the democrats
nominate in 2024 that's one of those
questions that there's no point
in in getting involved with now i have
no idea what's going to happen with joe
biden
in terms of re-election i'm thinking of
the next three months
covid coveted relief vaccines and then
the 2022 election
if joe biden doesn't run for re-election
then we'll think about
uh who i would like to see run in his
place josh hogan says david what are
your thoughts on the first migrant
facility for children opening under the
biden administration
disgusting i have a segment yesterday
actually it was on yesterday's podcast
came out on today's uh
in terms of a youtube clip and it is
called
um what is it called joe biden's biggest
uh broken promise so far
all right so i would love for you to
check out that clip i talk about that
issue
james says what do you think about the
new police reform bill that illinois
signed into law yesterday i didn't see
it i apologize i have not
looked at that yet dexy says please do a
summary about new york for non-members
all right maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow
uh let's see what is going on ah here we
go
we are standing by we have a podium a
and a lectern we have both
and here's joe bite good evening
everyone
justin we had good meetings
prime minister and i just included a
very productive bilateral meeting
the first of what i'm sure will be many
close and cooperative sessions
one of our last foreign trips i made was
as vice president was to
visit the prime minister in ottawa and
today
we're able to drive right into the many
vital issues of importance for both our
nations
for both our nations getting coveted
under control at home
and around the world is an immediate
priority and we committed to work
together to help prevent
future biological threats by
strengthening the world health
organization
supporting our bold targets under the
global health security agenda
cooperating in a global partnership
against the spread of weapons of mass
destruction
and engaging in other multilateral
institutions to vote
to promote transparency build capacity
and strengthen global norms we also
agreed to work in close cooperation
to strengthen the supply chain security
and resilience
and to ensure that canada and the united
states
are driving a robust economic recovery
that benefits everyone not just those at
the top
that's especially important because we
know that this pandemic
does not affect everyone the same way
women are dropping out of work in the
workforce the alarming rates
black latino and native are also in
other minorities are particularly hard
hit
we also agreed to work together on a
native species of recovery
using the tools available through the
small and medium enter surprise
chapter of our trade agreement to
support women
and minority-owned businesses we also
doubled down on our efforts to tackle
climate change it was really
really encouraging now that the united
states is back in the parish agreement
we intend to demonstrate our leadership
in order to spur other countries
to raise their own ambitions canada
and the united states are going to work
in lockstep
to display the seriousness of our
commitment at both home and abroad
to that end we're launching a high-level
climate ambition
ambition ministerial and to align our
policies and our goals
and to achieve net zero emissions
by 2050. prime minister trudeau and i
share an unwavering faith in the
capacity of our peoples
to meet the challenges of this new age
if we lead
with our core strengths our democratic
values
our diverse and dynamic peoples
we both recognize our responsibility as
leading democracies to defend our shared
values around the world
and to strengthen our own democracies at
home
that means rooting out systemic racism
and unconscious bias
from our institutions and our laws as
well as our hearts
today we agreed to re-establish the
cross-border crime
forum and work together to modernize our
approach to community safety
and to do all the most the much we can
do more to take on racism and
discrimination
in both our systems canada and the
united states are not only
vital partners or nato allies committed
to shared defense
the prime minister and i discussed our
work with our european allies to bolster
transatlantic security which includes
meeting our wales
commitments we also agreed to modernize
the north american aerospace defense
command norad
which is still the only bi-national
military command of its kind
and we will launch an expanded u.s
canadian arctic dialogue
to cover issues related to continental
security
economic and social development and
arctic governance
and finally coming on the hills of the
g7
meeting last friday it was an
opportunity for trump
prime minister trudeau and i to explore
our bilateral
partnership to reinforce and help drive
issues of concern
in our hemisphere and globally that
includes
coordinating our approaches to better
compete with china
and to counter threats to our interests
and values
let me reiterate our support for the
release
of the detained chinese associates
detained in china
two canadians michael spavar and
michael coving covering excuse me
human beings are not bartering ships
you know we're going to work together
until we get their safe return
canada and the united states will stand
together against abuse
of universal rights and democratic
freedoms
we're going to strengthen our shared
commitment to providing safe haven
for refugees and asylum seekers and so
much more
the united states has no closer and no
more important friend
than canada our nations share
close geography and history that will
forever bind us together
but our values are even more
consequential it's
but it's a shared spirit of our people
that's going to ensure
ours is a future of hope and opportunity
canadians and americans are innovative
creative entrepreneurial competitive
open hearted
and rights respected there's nothing we
cannot achieve
when we commit ourselves to it and when
we work together
as the closest a friend should we only
make each other stronger
so thank you again mr prime minister for
your friendship
and for your leadership i look forward
to when we're able to meet in person
and uh and all the canada and the united
states are going to accomplish together
so god bless you and thanks for today
thank you so much joe thank you
let me begin by saying that all of us
are thinking of our friends in texas
right now i know sask power has been
sending electricity down and as i told
the president
can we see him he's here to help however
we can mr president it's been great to
sit down with you this afternoon
this is of course not the first time
we've worked together back in 2016 i had
the pleasure of hosting you
here in ottawa as vice president over
dinner
i remember talking about how the
extraordinary friendship between canada
and the united states
has not just weathered changing seasons
it has grown ever deeper and stronger
well today we're taking our next step
forward
the president and i discussed the
ambitious new partnership
road map they had the pleasure of
hosting you here in ottawa
it will guide our country's work
together over the course remember
talking about how
the extraordinary friendship between got
it and the united states
has not just weathered changing seasons
it has grown ever deeper and stronger
well today we're taking our next step
forward
the president and i discussed the
ambitious new partnership
roadmap based on shared values and
priorities
that will guide our country's work
together over the coming years
beautiful in the face of covet 19 of
climate change
of rising inequality this is our moment
to act
so we're not wasting any time in getting
down to work
job one remains keeping people safe
and ending this pandemic this afternoon
the president and i discussed
collaboration to beat covid19 from
keeping key supplies moving and
supporting science and research
to joint efforts through international
institutions
we're standing united in this
i know the president and i are on the
same page when it comes to standing up
for the middle class
and people working hard to join it and
with millions of families relying on the
canada u.s partnership
this is work we must do together
just take the energy industry canadian
energy workers
power homes on both sides of the border
it goes to show that we're
all better off for this partnership
today that's a dig at texas and i
discussed
leveraging supply chains and support for
businesses
to create good good well well-paying
jobs
and help people who've been hardest hit
get back on their feet
canada innovation
occupying
i can mostly understand french he just
said the president and i have discussed
the possibility of a croissant
now i'm kidding the possibility of
working together on that issue
yeah the objectives are working together
to meet the paris climate accords
and working together on the carbon
guidelines
that defense
institutions this is actually kind of a
dig at trump talking about getting
re-involved in those multilateral and
global
global coalitions
we're facing tough times there's no
doubt but we're not
facing them alone canada and the united
states are each other's closest
allies most important trading partners
and oldest friends and we stand
united to beat this pandemic and build a
better tomorrow
and i know our bond will grow even
stronger
thank you mr president thank you joe for
your leadership
for your engagement and thank you in
advance for all the great work
we're going to be doing together next
year thank you justin
biden very impressed with trudeau you
could tell biden very very impressed
with justin trudeau there
uh all right so um any number of things
mentioned with some digs
i wish that the digs at trump would have
been in english rather than in french
uh but very very exciting exciting stuff
and resuming some of those relationships
once again
i'm going to try to uh do the stream
tomorrow
for the um gensake press briefing which
i believe has been scheduled
appreciate everybody who signed up and
supported maria busman just grabbed the
membership on my website
jody troupe has signed up so has
connor eggleston appreciate you guys
inconsolable continues to gift
subscriptions like their bitcoin
all over twitch it's wild what is going
on so thanks to everybody for joining me
let's get a raid out there why don't we
raid
oh i don't know let's raid uh
let's raid destiny today just for the
lulls it's been a long time since we did
um and we will be back so soon
so soon with more content i'll see
everybody
you